depuis quelques heures ce n'est pas une
mais trois attestations qui sont
disponibles sur le site du gouvernement
et sur l'application tous antico vide la
première vous la connaissez c'est
l'attestation de déplacement à
dérogatoire à remplir et à avoir en
permanence sur vous lorsque vous quittez
votre domicile un déplacement égale une
attestation à imprimer ou remplir
directement sur votre smartphone ou même
à remplir sur papier libre
les motifs les voici des déplacements
dans le cadre de votre activité
professionnelle si le télétravail et
n'est pas possible c'est la première
case vous cochez en revanche la deuxième
case si vous allez faire des courses
coup vous allez retirer une commande
elle est 3e et 4e mention pour des
déplacements dans le cadre de soins de
l'achat de médicaments ou pour motif
familial impérieux et l'assistance aux
personnes vulnérables ainsi que la garde
d'enfants sont autorisés à nouveau les
promenades les activités sportives
individuelles
les sorties pour les besoins de vos
animaux domestiques
ces déplacements doivent se faire dans
la limite d'une heure et dans un rayon
d'un kilomètre autour de votre domicile
et des cases existe aussi pour les
déplacements de personnes en situation
de handicap pour leurs accompagnants
pour des convocations judiciaires pour
se rendre dans des services publics ou
pour des missions d'intérêt général
enfin chose nouvelle c'est une nouveauté
tout en bas de cette attestation une
nouvelle case qui fait son apparition
pour aller chercher ou emmener votre
enfant à l'école
et justement afin de vous éviter de
remplir à chaque fois une nouvelle
attestation pour vous rendre au collège
à l'école au lycée un nouveau document
fait son apparition c'est le
justificatif de déplacements scolaires à
faire à cacheter par l'établissement
d'accueil de votre enfant cette
attestation est permanente et peut-être
conservé pendant toute la durée du
confinement
tout comme sept autres documents qui est
cette fois ci pour les déplacements
professionnels
une attestation permanente qui existait
déjà lors du premier confinement elle
doit être qu'acheter par votre employeur
une date de validité un moyen de
déplacement sont notamment a indiqué
quoi qu'il arrive hein vous devraient
être munis de l'un de ces trois
documents dès que vous quittez votre
domicile chaque contrevenant s'expose à
135 euros damende les amendes en cas de
récidive peuvent grimper jusqu'à 3000 7
en 50 euros et six mois de prison